they have this expectation going into
marriage that everything is going to be
perfect nothing is perfect Tia Mori and
husband Corey Hardrick divorcing after
14 years of marriage when you are
open-minded and saying okay you know
there are going to be some days where I
say something that I don't necessarily
mean if I'm like you know annoyed or
whatever
um you know forgive him you forgive
yourself I think that's the key E.T has
the docs Tia filed for divorce they're
asking for joint custody of their two
kids eleven-year-old son cree and
four-year-old daughter Cairo no requests
for spousal support and they'll follow
the terms of their prenup family is so
important to me on Instagram an
emotional statement from Tia she reveals
that she and Corey are going their
separate ways but insists they'll
maintain a friendship as they co-parent
she says in part quote these decisions
are never easy and not without sadness
I am grateful for the happy times we had
together and want to thank my friends
family and fans for your love and
support as we start this new chapter
moving forward in our lives to be in
Italy with again with our children and
our husbands it was just so amazing and
surreal surreal and just so wonderful
e-team was with Tia just last week the
actress still on cloud nine from her
dreamy Italian getaway with Corey cree
and Cairo in July there's the couple
holding hands enjoying the good life and
in the caption Tia gushes I love
traveling the world with you Corey
Hardrick just walking down the streets
and just having a great time and
drinking our Spritz just sharing Stories
the pair met in the early 2000s their
romance blossomed out of humble
beginnings
I was waiting on the bus stop we I was
at my first film her sister and I drove
by they saw me waiting they asked me to
give me a ride I was just like
embarrassed I was downtown yeah gave me
a ride and we were friends ever since
fast forward to April 2008.
and they tied the knot in Santa Barbara
Cory is really chill and he's very like
laid back and he's really cool but on
his wedding day
I I still feel like I've never seen him
smile as much and as big he cried when
both of our kids were born and he also
shed a tear on our wedding day they
welcomed their son in 2011 and their
daughter in 2018. I think having a boy
and a girl it's I mean I'm literally in
heaven I have the best little family
tree news of Tia split comes on the same
day her twin sister Tamara released her
Memoir no word on a TIA tell all just
yet but seems like the actress is ready
to be in open book is it your turn to
put out a memoir who you know what I was
thinking about this I think in the next
few years maybe like you have a lot of
stories I do I do I'm a little
mysterious I feel like I do have a lot
to say it's just when am I gonna say it
[Music]